bah de toute façon déjà c'était une très
mauvaise loi et elle est encore plus
mauvaise parce que c'est un durcissement
sur qui sera proche des thèses laurent
wauquiez de l'extrême droite et on a une
course à l'échalote a essayé de rendre
la france tellement détestable pour le
monde entier en croyant que c'est ainsi
qu'on va pouvoir conjurer une
immigration qui s'accroît donc moi je
trouve ça aussi très dangereux dangereux
à la fois et pas très humain même
inhumain parfois quand je pense à la
manière dont sont traités les mineurs
dans ce texte puisque les rétentions et
son possible et pour les mineurs isolés
et pour les enfants accompagnés
il ya d'autres exemples qui seront
données la réalité c'est qu'on habitue
les gens à au motif de il y aurait trop
de l'immigration il y aurait trop de
réfugiés qui viendrait nous submerger on
habitue les gens à l'inhumain et pour
que ce soit 21 % de français estiment
que la politique française est trop
laxiste en matière mire mais on ne cesse
de le redire ça on ne cesse de faire une
loi pour dire que les pas encore assez
forte et qu'il faut encore tous les deux
ans on ferait mieux de s'occuper d'avoir
des lois qui fonctionne de donner les
moyens
moi je crois très important qu'en effet
le délai de six mois pour que les gens
puissent savoir clairement s'ils sont
demandeurs d'asile reconnus ou pas soit
tenue mais ça n'est pas au prix du non
respect du droit et par ailleurs je
crois très important qu'à partir du
moment où les gens ne sont pas retenus
demandeur d'asile tout en les traitant
humainement et correctement nous
organisions un départ pour retrouver
leur pays d'origine
enfin ça fait des lustres qu'on nous dit
la solution c'est l'aide au
développement dans les pays du sud mais
on fait quoi
l'europe on fait quoi à part baratiner
et puis après pleurer ou après fermer
nos frontières de manière totalement
irrationnel et inopérante surtout
inopérantes
donc tout ça et d'une d'une fabuleuse
hypocrisie et moi je crois que dans la
période où on voit ce qui se passe aux
etats unis
attitude de tram vis-à-vis de
l'immigration quand on voit que ça même
de notre propre europe on interdit en
hongrie aux ong de venir en aide aux
migrants qu'on respecte plus le droit de
l'indépendance de la justice en pologne
ou en hongrie et que l'union européenne
veut beau tout ça c'est secondaire par
contre les critères de convergence à
pour la grèce la lega faut payer ce nom
et trébuchants ça va pas durer longtemps
et la france doit s'honorer de tenir sur
ses principes et d'être opérationnel
genou je ne mets pas en opposition
l'efficacité et le respect scrupuleux
des principes un mot sur la manière dont
se sont déroulés les débats au sénat
cette semaine vous avez présidé vous la
séance dans la nuit de jeudi à vendredi
les incidents de séance se sont
multipliées provoquée par l'absence de
sénateurs de droite pourtant majoritaire
comment vous qualifiez vous la manière
dont se sont déroulés les débats dans
l'hémicycle
c'est vrai qu'on a une grande absence de
nos collègues républicains en tout cas
c'était c'est évident hier
moi je pense que ça n'est pas simplement
une espèce de mauvaise organisation de
ce groupe qui quand même est bien huilée
dans les traditions parlementaires
je crois qu'il y à un flottement chez
une partie des électeurs des sénateurs
de droite qui quand même même sous
nicolas sarkozy avait refusé des
décisions qui aujourd'hui sont votées
par leur camp voir proposer par leur
camp donc qui quand même ne sont pas
très à l'aise et qui voit ce qui se
passe qui sentent bien qu'on l'ait pris
par cette espèce de dérive au lieu
d'être solide sur nos bases est
opérationnel dans l'action et puis il y
à il ya aussi le fait que ce texte même
si c'est le texte amendé du sénat c'est
d'abord le texte du gouvernement et
gérard collomb qui lui en rajoute une
sauce vous parler d' incidents de séance
quand vous entendez le ministre de
l'intérieur vous dire il ya des enfants
à sociaux on sait bien qu'un enfant qui
a traversé l'europe truc il est tendue
dans un traumatisme
il n'est pas simplement victime il est
souvent est pris il peut amener est
violent il peut avoir amené des
problèmes psychiatriques
un enfant n'est pas asocial par nature
il est désocialisée
il est en difficulté et la réponse que
de lui apporter c'est une réponse de
respect de l'enfant d'abord et de
l'humanité vous voyez que tout ça fait
qu'une partie des sénateurs même de goût
du camp républicain n'est pas très à
l'aise ça